allora ragazzi oggi faccio smr perché la
mia voce la perdono ho iniziato a
leggere un libro non era una brutta idea
iniziato a leggerlo sentivo delle
presenze crederci questo sito questo
devo andare a controllare linda la nuova
segretaria spero che sia bene ha
iniziato a leggere un libro ma non si
legge un libro da lunghi e prelati lui
si legge non so cosa ci abbiano voce
oggi comunque the book signori farò tipo
smr per chiaramente mi sto oggi sto
perdendo la voce non so perché
innanzitutto se sei seduto nudo e pelato
non leggi un libro così non lo leggi c'è
satana ci sono i cerchi sa di le stelle
sataniste c'è una foto di mio cugino
non leggete quando i libri sono così per
favore poi mi devo giocare gli host i
giochi comunque non mi devo alterare che
ci sto già perdendo la voce quindi oggi
faremo un horror calmo e mi vedrete
impegnato nello schierare perché per me
sclerare significa perdere la voce
ancora di più perché già non ce l'ha
oggi cominciamo
non c'è bisogno della storici chi non ho
bisogno adesso della storia di certo
fammi andare avanti come uno stronzo e
far prendere dopo tornando indietro
tanto io ho tempo da perdere
questo bene cioè la cosa più inutile del
mondo qua ma va bene buongiorno a c'è
una macchinetta del merendine e troppo
pesante ho bisogno di uno strumento per
muoverla che cosa cazzo ti serve muovere
una macchinetta del delle merendine ma
che problemi hai nel cervello giacché
leggi libri così alla storage ecco qua
adesso non si apre devo trovare la
storia di chi ho scritto stronzo io qua
stronzo c'è scritto comunque devo
trovare la mia segretaria in tutto
questo si chiama linda ma si fa presa
porta
non vado in quella panzino voglio morire
vado in questa porta ammazza mi voglio
morire perché non voglio andare a
prendere la chiave del cos'è questo
faccio un bagno linda tesoro non in un
centro quasi books proprio sono andate
in bagno tornerò presto linda con la
faccina che sorride malino stava
sorridendo tesoro non so cosa tu sia
anzi sì lo so perché probabilmente hai
le tue cose però vorrei non disturbarti
e dow e la birra vuoi una birra un po
più saporita linda si tuffa dentro stai
bene che casino cioè stai bene se sto
piangendo e c'è del sangue perché che da
fare apri questa porta per l'amor di dio
linda linda c'e del coso schifo per
terra tipo ci sono ragnatele per terra
linda non so se ti stai mangiando dei
ragni non lo so linda e da non riesco a
fare linda per favore
apre questo porta lindhart che cazzo
piange o porca vacca bene e ti lascio lì
è stato un po che cosa è successo si è
risucchiata nel cesso ragazzi orribile
vabbè la madonna e prendi un una
spazzola per il ces non c'è bisogno di
spingere gli assorbenti di sotto con il
piede di porco però grazie lo prendo c'è
anche un rosario rosario non mi serve
tanto rosa in the basement chemello
horror grazie che lo scrittore che mi
sembra una puntata dei teletubbies la
fine è vicina fine vicina a tre
chilometri da tempo è tutto al contrario
perché ovviamente siamo i fratelli di
satana in questo gioco però almeno io
sono nudo insomma faccio le cose fatte
bene
today che devo andare esattamente
prendere le cose nel basement non mi
serve la chiave noi teniamo chiusa
quella merda di storage teniamo che
posso spostare questa roba qua vita col
piede di porco
c'è un piede di porco non sono danni
serve ma cielo quindi usiamo il piede di
porco no uscita effettivamente l'uscita
in questo momento è molto più che fa
molta più gola che andarsene nel
basement però porco del demonio non sia
previene apriamo questo sì ma stai calmo
allora e lo prendiamo lo prendi ancora
per il porto che siccome ti serve
non lasciamolo lì per terra tanto c'è
solo un tasto rosso io l'ho premo e
bellissimo che sto facendo un horror
cercando di contenere la voce quindi
sembra proprio smr ma lo sto facendo
solo e unicamente perché mi manca la
voce e fatemi sapere se vi piacciono i
video più smr perché potrei pensare di
farli sempre così anche se mi fa molto
strano non schiamazzare sarà perché urlo
come una scimmia da dieci anni quando
faccio i video dove vado porco del
demonio morto ieri dove vado dove sono
nudo cosa vuoi dalla mia vita four capa
casa cosa che si è subito sta roba a sia
per tassa porto che
tutto sto casino è permesso il citofono
citofono progetto grazie stesso telefono
stefano indietro ok che scusa
l'inchiesta su telefono posso entrare
allora allora allora allora è giallo
voce non mi fate incazzare per favore
partiamo che facciamo un'altra cosa non
andiamo lì hanno un'altra parte del tipo
qua dentro qua dentro inter non so la
vincerà un telefono che suonava eastwood
arcaini da flashlight from my locker
ho bisogno della torcia dal mio
armadietto tua sorella o bisogna
riaccendere la luce questa utile raja
sporca di sangue guardavano giallo già
sporcata devi fare niente tu chi chi li
linda madonna comunque io ragazzi io
questa situazione non l'accetto
continuiamo ragazzi non posso entrare ha
detto perché troppo buio però posso
entrare nel cesso dove una star si sta
cambiando la assorbendo non so comunque
ragazzo aveva che è che ho una mano dal
muro che è successo a perché questo era
il telefono una mano dal muro linda e
non sapevo avesse poteri di
trasposizione del corpo attraverso le
mura mi fa piacere genitori mi fai apri
non facciamo commenti questa è locker a
devo trovare la loki archi pure ma
veramente se volete prendervi per il
culo dall'inizio è fatto dall'inizio
io vorrei anche trovati vestiti visto
che il fino a proprio tre sono ancora
modo ho trovato there and track cosa ho
trovato ben tra katy perry lo pisa e la
porta don't worry qualcosa mi dice che
questa roba si sposta adesso
esatto e ciò la chiave perché mai perché
non dovrei lasciare la chiave del mio
locker dietro dietro questo perché non
dovrebbe non perché no perché no certo
mi sembra giusto c'è ancora un rosario
meno ma io prenderei prima rosario e per
quello comunque andiamo avanti con la
fer
con l'app con la torcia come flashlight
stava dicendo ma non sono english no si
sa mai
io prenderei anche lascia zio per over
fai quello che vuoi
linda linda linda mia linda bella questa
è la leva manca manca la leva per aprire
i per linda questa non è linda gli serve
la leva per aumentare la potenza anzi
per accendere proprio generatore e a
questo qua serve tantum verde per la
gola servire biancame realtà cioè mio
stesso prezzo è andata il binario 9
trequarti minchiam correrò non funziona
sento dei respiri strani chiudo la porta
io più vado di sotto più mi sembra di
scendere negli inferi però però però
paolo il medico paolo salve
lei è nudo come me o no li linda ma come
linda ma come linda cosa linda dove cosa
doc come linda don backy sosto legge o
comunque questa è la leva del generatore
io la prendo cece useful fa piacere che
qualcuno si impegna anche a scrivere sui
muri con con le scritte che che non sono
attaccato a loro ma escono un po blinda
sei veramente nulla in questo momento
tanto lo sono anche io quindi utile che
che faccio le prediche vado di sopra la
catena molto molto bello ovunque fin ora
sto gioco tranne il fatto che ora non ho
voce la più penso che in dieci anni sia
il primo video che faccio senza voce
ragazzi valente non mi è mai successo
siamo questo ok lescot l'ha detto pure
lui l'ex co quindi come di solito l'ha
detto lui è perfetto
io lo accetta la prenderei la prenderei
madonna kansas ascensore porco demonio
buy
ok nessuno ha ficcato l'amaro
tesoro signori io spero che il video vi
sia piaciuto mi dispiace anche perché la
voce non ce l'ho e quindi tanto adesso
devo registrare un altro paio di video
perché questi giorni non sono a casa
quindi registrano molto smr spero che
questa smr vi piaccia perché se il fatto
è un problema però per un paio di giorni
sarò così un bacino
ci vediamo al prossimo video iscrivetevi
al canale ricordatevi che sono il canale
il numero uno degli horror perché
contenuti così il ricordo della ragazzi
[Musica]